all right guys bang-bang Monday lunch
money time well while she's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get our lunch money right I'm here with
the beautiful and intelligent Polina
Mayer Innova she finally has the right
outfit on she's got a black t-shirt
thank you for listening to the rules
what's up the only reason I'm wearing
this is because today is our friend's
birthday he is turning 19 years young
fellas 19 years young what do you have
to say to the people on your birthday
get money get paid because block Phi is
sponsoring lunch money
they've got three products they've got a
crypto exchange where you can buy and
sell crypto currencies you can deposit
crypto you can earn a u.s. dollar loan
or my favorite product as an investor in
a user is an interest-bearing account
you deposit crypto they pay you up to
eight point six percent 8py on the
interest-bearing account it works just
like your bank go deposit money and earn
interest click on the link in the
description or use black Viacom slash
lunch money and for a fun surprise a
birthday surprise stay tuned until the
end of this video I've seen the video at
the end of the video you want to stay
around for this it's pretty ridiculous
what's going on with Jim bankruptcies hi
Jim like Jay I am it's not a person it's
Jim will you go workout in the gym
go ahead who are you today it's my
birthday I can do whatever I want guys
that's up with the national gym meeting
come on let's go let's go we got our we
got us dead speeding no we don't have
time this isn't a relationship show this
is a business show that's good because I
know you're ridiculous you just so
everyone knows you see that right there
I caught her I know what she's about to
do he's still salty okay nACCHO gym
chain 24-hour Fitness is filed for
bankruptcy after COBIT forces facilities
to shut down for months so technically
they're not they are expecting to keep a
majority of their locations open by the
end of June because they have secured
250mm
dollars and funding but the CEO said if
it were not for ku vat19 and its
devastating effects we would not be
filing for chapter 11
maybe you shouldn't charge $10 a month
for a gym membership that's a wild idea
yeah 24-hour fitness I don't think is
actually $10 but it's a cheaper chain
than most and okay but gold's gym filed
in May for bankruptcy so of course
because the gym business isn't a good
business when you charge so little the
whole idea of charge a little bit of
money at high volumes isn't a great
business model especially when the gyms
closed obviously and the other thing is
now you have these boutique fitness
centers popping up so they're all over
New York City all over other places and
then too is you now are starting to see
things like peloton treadmills the thing
what is it tonal or whatever right like
on the wall hey those things are keeping
people out of gym how is Equinox doing
they certainly don't charge a low price
I'll tell you that but that's the whole
that's kind of the point right is
Equinox has a much higher profitability
than some of these other gyms and so my
guess is that it's not going well for
them but they still are able to prevent
any sort of bankruptcy filing and the
other thing too is if you're an investor
and you're looking at do I want to
invest in Gold's Gym 24-hour fitness or
Equinox
obviously the financials of an equinox
is much more attractive from an
investment standpoint than these other
gyms so at the end of the day they're
not gonna go away they'll go through
their chapter 11 filings they'll come
back out on the other side probably with
new management the equity will get wiped
out people start going to gym I just
find it so fascinating that all these
businesses are like if kovat had not
happened this wouldn't happen to us but
at the same time you just need to be
ready for all sorts of crazy things to
happen to your business I mean they
never probably thought they'd shut down
for three months I'm less empathetic to
the I'm empathetic to the idea of hey
this was unpredictable yes agreed the
fact of the government forced you to
shut down your business for three months
or two months whatever it's been yes
that is very hard to see in a
pre-pandemic world what I am NOT
empathetic to is what did you do about
right and so you look like the boutique
fitness centers for example a lot of
them they immediately pivoted to
some sort of online training they had
people paying them of course not gonna
make as much revenue as they did make
but they took steps to try to mitigate
the damage a lot of these chains didn't
do that right so either they fired
employees but they basically just shut
down and just took it on the chin and at
the end of the day like you get hit in
the face enough times you file for
bankruptcy so that is the beauty of
entrepreneurship is it's always gonna
have ups and downs this was a major down
got hit in the face
you gotta respond the gym does it and so
they found for bankruptcy what's going
on with Cove in fraud okay there's a lot
of fraud in the age of kovat apparently
criminals are busy and creative so in
the most widespread scam criminals are
filing fake unemployment claims on
behalf of real people who have not lost
their jobs hitting one state after
another how is this possible how can
they do this I bet you it's not nearly
as big of a problem as people want it to
seem we want this is a highly
politicized thing and what people will
do it's kind of like voter fraud right
like is there voter fraud absolutely is
there unemployment insurance fraud
absolutely is it widespread I think
that's where the debate happens my guess
is that it's much less popular than
people actually believe and if you look
at it I mean those two things were the
same so the whole idea is just like
there was a week where six point six
million unemployment claims got filed
two weeks in a row
back in March right or beginning of
April how many of those were fraudulent
claims that's the thing we don't know
well my guess is that it's less than
0.1% what if it's more I find that
incredibly hard to lie because the
amount that you would have to be able to
do like what are you gonna do I say you
do a thousand people you get all of
their information you file you're
successful you don't get caught all that
kind of stuff a thousand out of six
point six million okay it's like
non-material but get this Washington
state seems to have been hit hardest
with hundreds of millions of dollars in
benefits siphoned off okay but hundreds
of millions of dollars out of billions
of dollars
significant is it yes there was just
three trillion dollars and also what I
would say it is money well here's the
other thing that I would say is I find
it hard to believe that people actually
took millions of dollars from the state
government because the the biggest it
like the biggest coronavirus fraud that
I had heard of so far today was like
some guy got eighty million dollar
government contract to produce
ventilators and never had the ventilator
show up hmm
right so like if that was the biggest
scam so far yeah is it possible
yeah sure somebody could steal hundreds
of myself but from one state maybe look
never say never 2020 while there's alien
signals there's pandemics there's all
kinds of crazy stuff I just I just don't
know that's kind of how I operate like
it could be big because it's 2020 yeah
but the other thing too just to be clear
is I'm talking specifically about
unemployment what I think that might be
included in a number like hundreds of
millions could be there's also other
types of frauds that are going on so
things like people are pretending to be
the financial assistance or the finance
person at a university called college
students and say you gotta pay us money
right or they're they're preying on
elderly people right hey there's you
know covetous ravaging your demographic
you axe pay us this money will protect
you all that kind of stuff right and so
it's not just unemployment my guess is
that the state of Washington would this
would be all over the headlines if they
had hundreds of millions of dollars fall
from that employee business I mean it's
just we live in a time where I feel like
you literally can have these people
scammers who are working 9:00 to 5:00
trying to get more sophisticated and in
better and there's two groups of
scammers though this is where criminals
right this way you have to remember one
is I do it for a living and like I am a
I am a criminal a tional scammer yes and
I try to make a living doing this
the other type and the more pervasive
type of fraud we have a friend who
always says like any times like this
when people get desperate is when fraud
increases when risk increases that's
basically because what happens is like
hey I've been making my pain
let's say on my rent over and over and
over again for months and months and
months and months I've been do that for
years right then all of a sudden I get
in a dire situation and so what do I do
I fudged the numbers one time say oh
just this one time and that's gonna
allow me to pay the rent this this month
and the next month comes go oh just one
more time and the next thing you know
six months later like you've committed
fraud in a very material way it's not so
much that like that person is a bad
person right like they're not a
professional criminal is actually that
they were put in a desperate situation
and they made the wrong decision right
still wrong so you're saying that's more
prevalent than the professional scammers
well I think that prevalence on a
percentage basis so like out of all of
the crime that happens it's much more
often that people were just put in a bad
situation and made a bad decision I
think now on a dollar amount standpoint
the professionals are going after
millions tens of millions hundreds of
millions of dollars and the you know
local small business owner that just
makes a bad decision because they're put
in a desperate situation yeah they're
more probably in the thousands of tens
of thousands rich well if you were ever
unsure of something as a scam tell
somebody before you act like my great
grandmother who's 91 sometimes when I
call her on the phone and she I she
thinks everybody's a scammer so I have
to literally convince her it's me
otherwise she'll think I'm trying to
scam her that was a scam she's not 91
she's 90 go ahead - impossible
hey guys like that I read the internet
so much I know that Elena's
great-grandmother is 90 and not ninety
one boy pays attention go ahead
impossible foods okay yep so Burger King
is adding impossible foods as meatless
sausage on its breakfast menu nationwide
is this a big win win for the meatless
meat companies is it sausage if there's
no sausage in it
yeah it's meatless sausage but that is
not sausage just talking about sausages
I'm just saying you can't call it a
sausage if it is meatless well cuz
sausage is meat well that's that's what
they're calling it now you can call it
impossible sausage because it's
impossible that this is a sausage but
that's pretty much it
what did that company get sued for
improbable foods yeah somewhere in
Europe somebody's
somebody was trying to basically compete
with them that's fine would you go eat
this yes I can I can try it I'm just not
a big meatless meat person I wouldn't I
wouldn't need it like the really no I
would eat it why because McDonald's is
better than Burger King oh my god okay
but do you think that this is a
significant you know move on the part of
impossible foods to get this recognized
nationwide and become more you want me
to see you around the corner you want me
to see around the corner for you I'll
give you a peek into the future
majority of the meat products that we
have on menus at these places are going
to be replaced by meatless products and
then it's gonna come out 20 30 50 years
later is horrible for us okay but can I
challenge you on that sure I don't think
that the meat the real meat you're
eating at Burger King right now is
actually either you know one real or too
good for you so what are you eating but
what I would argue is that more and more
so there's been faces there was really
bad stuff then they started to get a
little bit healthier and now they're
going to this meatless thing what I'm
saying is that if you have lab-grown
meat so as to the difference there's
lab-grown meat versus plant based on the
plant-based stuff is whatever it's
plant-based stuff that's gonna be fine
but the lab-grown stuff we do not
understand the long-term effects on
humans eating this lab-grown meat and my
guess is that it's gonna be like sugar
right there's a period in time where
actually sugar was thought to be okay
now all I was like oh my god sugar so
bad it's killing everybody smoking no
problem oh wait now it's killing
everybody my guess is that lab-grown
meats gonna do that same thing it's
gonna take decades to get right because
if you think about it there's chemicals
there's a lot of salt there's a lot of
things involved to make it taste like
real meat especially if it's grown in a
lab and you're not even trying to make
it I'm all natural I don't want any
chemicals I don't want any meat only
that stuff in my body
he literally ate an ice cream cake the
other day was like frosting the once a
year oh you do it once a year
relax it's fine you can put a little
poison in your body once a year no
problem kwibi what's up what's up with
them losing who called it heel boy right
here call me that's not the point of
this okay this article is an
investigation done by Wall Street
Journal who somehow
always has the scoop on kwibi reportedly
Jeffrey Katzenberg and Meg Whitman who
are the two co-founders of kwibi meg is
the CEO
they are like at war with each other
ever their contrasting leadership styles
isn't the leadership styles or is it
because the startup has gone down the
drain you know my father told me one
time there ain't nothing more fun than
winning so you know what that means
nothing less fun than losing and so
that's what's happening they're losing
you can call whatever you want you could
try to explain why it's happening they
raised billions of dollars like almost
two billion dollars and they have less
than two million users less than two
million users fewer whatever it is they
have not performed and the reason is
content sucks the coronavirus happen
they their entire thesis was wrong on
the horizontal video sub whatever you
want to say at the end of the day you
reach two billion dollars it's not
working and you have two people who are
egotistical it if you've run a big
company like both of them have you have
to have some ego teeth well of course
then they have all the experience and
whatever see your ego and then you get
together and you just literally hold on
so what heads
here's that's interesting Whitney was
supposed to shine in a period 'like
coronavirus people have nothing to do
let's give them content that didn't
happen obviously because they're not
commuting whatever regardless of why it
didn't work kwibi is now trying to
conserve the little cash the little cash
it has left it has a lot of cash left
but anyway they're trying to the company
estimated that it would need to reduce
its content and marketing budgets by a
combined 300 million in its first year
that is a lot of money and then Meg is
taking a pay cut but they said nothing
about Jeffrey Katzenberg just so we're
clear you can go back to one of the
earlier episodes of lunch money and I
told you you guys want to watch somebody
like two billion dollars on fire Exhibit
A I told you number one reason why
businesses like this don't work you
raise too much money up front you don't
that product market fit you think it's
gonna be this big reveal
that's not how companies get built it's
not how Facebook got bill it's not how
Amazon got built
Google got built Twitter I'll just go
demo on every large company in the world
was not built this way because it's not
how you build companies so these people
who by the way are executives they're
not entrepreneurs big big difference
these people are trying to basically
enforce their will it's an egotistical
movement resolve this money I know the
right thing to do I'm gonna build a
product that you guys want doesn't work
that way they're getting humbled by the
way I actually hope that they're
successful I want every entrepreneur to
be successful right it's just that you
can see this come from a mile away and
it's unfortunate that they let two
billion dollars on fire okay I'm cooking
up Disney Disney there's a manager Oh
Disney doesn't even see them as a
competitor problem but anyway I think
Disney might have invested the god oh I
think they did anyway okay
so do you know Barbara Streisand yeah
the Streisand effect no oh wait yes I
read the entire oh my god I forgot those
were linked
yep Barbara Streisand create the
Streisand effect it's one's a piece of
negative news is written about you and
instead of ignoring it you actually
fight it and when you fight it gives it
more fuel and more attention and ends up
working out even worse and worse and
worse
wait do you remember what the case was
no don't care I just I see an effect
when people talk she's she's let him go
she has albums and she's a star
basically so she gave X star okay
she gave George Floyd's six year old
daughter she mailed her Disney shares
that's pretty cool it's not awesome do
you think that it would be smart to give
little kids shares of companies that you
think are good to hold in the long term
I mean I feel like this is a very much
an emotional thing this is not driven to
education or anything like that what
you're talking about is in most cases
people want to help students learn or
kids learn about my education gianna
George Floyd's daughter even though
she's six she'll probably get interested
in this me like what are these shares
that I have here in this folder for sure
in it kind of it's an impetus to them
yeah I mean look I I absolutely think
that uh that that is
a big likelihood and by the way Barbra
Streisand kudos to you yeah love this
you know yeah I don't really know what
else to say about it other than I wish
every kid in America got a financial
education that's that's the real
pandemic forget coronavirus real
pandemic is we don't educate people on
personal finance or how money works if
we started doing that there'd be
absolute chaos in the streets people
just stealing from the poor all right go
ahead
let's have a double inundation I'm not
ready for any more engagements
I don't want virus invasions I don't
want a lien invasions what's going on
Paul well this is a great story
Poland accidentally like the Polish
military accidentally invaded the Czech
Republic last month and call that just
the big misunderstanding like literally
the accident okay so Polish soldiers
mistakenly cross the country's border
with Czech Republic in late May before
setting up there and then the soldiers
started turning away Czech citizens who
are attempting to visit a church in
their own country okay Poland got pissed
so sorry the Czech Republic got pissed
is this something where they drove down
a road and they thought that they were
actually at the border and in fact they
just like misjudged where they were that
sounds like what it is but Poland is not
say they just they're just saying it's a
misunderstanding with taking care of it
my got it okay I mean that's much
different than what I thought you were
gonna say which is like they went and
did a bunch of dumb stuff I'm like oh
whoops no but I mean look at the end of
the day when you're you know take a back
road for example there's no line that
says here it is or when you cross
certain country lines sometimes it's
literally marked by the military be
really don't think about when you drive
so for example when we drove from
Bulgaria degrees a clear mark because
the military made that mark like they
set it up oh that's how you knew you
were crossing from Bulgaria in degrease
right but if that wasn't their military
well usually they work together to sign
up right but if somebody got there first
and so how do we know that's actually
the line but what if they're off by a
hundred yards or a mile and then there's
a church you want to go visit
and then they're like oh sorry you can't
go oh man I don't know I think it's just
probably some dumb soldiers making dumb
mistakes it's fine by the way stay out
of other people's country okay lunch
money time $100 to anyone who signed up
last week
well not anyone - one person who signed
up last week Gator boy 52:13 I'm not
gonna say your email address
I've emailed you you get a hundred you
pick Gator boy imma for two Gators fan
better than Georgia that's actually
false Gator boy and I like the name
Gator boys Gator boy Gator boy
Gator boy I just want to get something
off my chest that happened to me this
weekend out of the how many millions of
people were there in the world seven
billion what go ahead
well do you hear that noise okay so many
people on this planet we went to the
beach the beach and we were sitting
there this weekend just sitting minding
my own business and guess what happened
a bird pooped on ER a seagull pooped on
me like all the people dropped missiles
just drop the missile right there was
like everyone on the beach was that one
yeah it's a seashell I was sitting there
traumatized it was on my knee by the way
it wasn't on my head thank God but it
was so very traumatic no direct hit
the bogey east on you it's like it was
like literally dropping a missile right
in the most dramatic part was sitting
there and Hugh and his brothers were
playing spike ball and it was like guys
I think I just got poop John and they
just doing like okay and they're like
going back to playing spike ball how did
you not hear it was such a big event
anyway well it sounded like more like a
personal problem that's something that
involves me I've heard I've heard it
seven years of good luck if you get
pooped on my words yeah somebody who got
pooped on made that up for sure all
right play your video this is what I got
from me from Polina
for my birthday
hey what's going on Anthony wow man is
your birthday 32 right your fiancee
Paulina told me give me a shout-out man
and what we doing we're brother
everything is almost cleared open it's
ugh come on it's tough but it's the way
it's about the big corner I'm in Bitcoin
2 out of Toronto but it's gonna hit one
day but either way light was a good
journey right now huh it's teaching us
how to be more productive using our
minds using our brain you want to call
that blinding brains well either way man
is your birthday man hope you have a
great way successful life and good luck
with you marriage and the happy birthday
so your marriage he said if anyone
wanted to know Dennis Rodman owns
Bitcoin that's it for lunch Monday today
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right including Dennis Rodman see
you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by black 5 so go check them out there's
a link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
black fire than you are of me block lies
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy playin in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends